pas et demande charles roux qui est
journaliste et écrivain prix goncourt
1966 voudrions bien et vous publiez
alors vous êtes vraiment fasciné par par
chanel
parce qu'après l'irrégulière ou mon
itinéraire channel vous publiez donc un
album sur intitulé le temps channel aux
éditions cheyne grasset et c'est quoi
c'est la transcription en images du
précédent livre c'est ça oui j'ai essayé
de d'exploiter les toutes les documents
photographiques que j'avais mis ensemble
pour nous pour me guider à travers la
biographie de chanel et puis très vite
je me suis aperçu que on ne travaillait
pas par l'image comme on travaille avec
le mot et que au lieu de raconter
uniquement l'histoire de cette femme
exceptionnelle de ce casse sociale qui
était chanel en vérité j'écrivais sans
le vouloir et par l'image plutôt
l'histoire de son temps et en fait j'ai
été très intéressé par le rapport que
j'avais avec l'image et par le fait
qu'on ne fait pas dire à une image ce
qu'elle ne veut pas dire ce quand on
fait le bilan de la vie de chanel coco
chaleur le pli coco à cause d'une
chanson on l'appelait à cause d'une
chanson qui était une chanson quelle
chance et chanter en beuglant et qui
avait un titre très long qui datait de
l'époque de la tour eiffel qui
s'appelait qui qu'a vu coco sur le
trocadéro
les officiers qui voulait cette chanson
qui voulait un bis trouvé que c'était
plus simple d'appeler coco et le nom lui
est resté
et pourquoi êtes vous fait signer pareil
je ne sais pas si je suis fasciné par
elle veut que je croise les livres tous
maintenant je pense par jeu franchement
je crois que je suis plutôt fasciné par
son cas c'est pas tout à fait la même
chose je me demande comment une femme
est en partie dans la vie avec les
difficultés incroyables et misère dans
laquelle elle a commencé et la tristesse
son éducation
la dureté de sa vie et comment elle est
devenue une impératrice des
les folles et plus tard une impératrice
de la mode comment il est devenu cet
extraordinaire chef d'entreprise je
crois que c'est un cas unique
quand on fait le bilan de sa vie le chef
d'entreprise 10 sur 10 vie privée 0 sur
10 de livres rapidement a dit mais c'est
après ça quand même et c'est un échec
complet
ce qui est d'ailleurs en soi déjà aussi
un cas c'est à dire fascinant personnage
à cause de ceux de cette confrontation
de la l'extraordinaire réussite
commerciale et cette extraordinaire
ratage de sa vie sentimentale
oui je vais vous raconter donner les
noms tous les hommes avec qui elle a
vécu parfois longtemps parfois très
rapidement et chaque fois rencontre des
hommes qui sont tous mariés qui ne
jamais lui propose de mariage non je
crois d'ailleurs c'est ça c'est ça son
histoire elle est elle vivait nous
pensons nous que 1925 était une époque
légère et fofolle
en vérité c'était un 19ème siècle ayant
un peu bu trop de cocktails mais les
interdits restés les mêmes
elle avait derrière l expérience du
beuglant et l'expérience lui beuglant
étaient inadmissibles dans la société
dans laquelle elle avait essayé de
percer et au fait tout et la laisse pas
si elle était restée dans la société de
ses origines je crois qu'elle aurait
trouvé un homme qu'il aurait aimé pour
sa beauté pour son charme mais elle
essayait de s'introduire dans une
société qui ne voulait pas d'elle et
c'est son droit mais c'est ce qui fait
d'elle un personnage de roman
censé ignorer il n'y aurait pas le
personnage chanel y aurait une réussite
propose de feuilleter